armando salgueiro the miami herald had
an interesting story yesterday about
tuatanga vailoa the dolphins came out
immediately after the season ended and
said that tua will be the starting
quarterback in 2021 that came straight
from gm chris greer
coach brian flores on board salguero has
and look you can understand why the
players would not want to be named here
three unnamed players who aren't sold
on tua and that's not a shock i think
most people
other than brian flores and chris greer
are
taking a let's wait and see we're not
quite sure what this guy is going to be
and we're concerned he's never going to
be as good as justin herbert was in his
rookie year
yeah well there has to be some sort of
concern
there and as we we've talked about
before let's say players once they get
to see you in person and do all that
stuff
they know more times than not and let's
not forget
a lot of these dolphin suppliers saw joe
burrow and justin herbert on the field
this year so they saw that and they went
wait our guy doesn't look like those two
guys
so i i think anybody who watched
football and has somewhat of an
understanding
can if you're going to be totally
unbiased and realistic about it you're
going to go wait
hey i like to uh i saw a few things i
like
but wait how good can he be there i
think that's a legitimate question for
anybody watching the sport right now
now the question is going to be like
kind of what you said there at the end
do chris greer and brian flores are they
really
all in i i think and i've heard some
people who know people down there in
miami where
there is true questions about tua within
the organization
and i think that the conversation of
we might draft another quarterback is
not dead yet in miami
i don't think it's dead and i think
that's going to be something to watch
for they could be one of those
you know under the radar teams that's
doing quarterback diligence here
and don't be shocked so i'll be
surprised or
interested to see where this goes
because i certainly don't think he did
anything in my mind
to go oh he's the future there's no
doubts about them and we're good to go i
don't know about that yet
two points one they hold the third
overall pick in the draft by virtue of
laramie tunsil kenny stills trade the
texans would have had the third pick the
dolphins have it
you need to do your due diligence on all
the quarterbacks if you have that pick
because you may be trading that pick
and you're in your best possible
position to negotiate
an ideal trade with someone who's coming
up to get a quarterback in that spot if
you're able to
say yeah but he can do this and he can
do that and we've looked at this and
we've looked at that
and that's why you do the work up on the
quarterbacks and then in the process of
doing the workup
if you decide that maybe maybe one of
these guys is better than tua
you got to have the flexibility to do it
but the other reality chris is there's
no reason for them to say that now
there's no reason to telegraph it now
there's no reason to undermine tua now
because if you don't find
an upgrade you got to love the one
you're with
and you don't want to have him spending
the
months of january february march and
april worrying
are they going to find somebody better
than me are they going to try to find
somebody better than me or am i their
guy oh they told me i'm the guy
i can focus on my preparations for 2021.
mike if he is being if he's in reality
he
he knows that's got to be a question he
he has to know that
by the way you got benched twice by ryan
fitzpatrick
you know in big moments he came in and
tore it up
right away when he came in he was
running the same place you were running
and then you know yes the end of the
year we saw ryan fitzpatrick can come in
the game change and
tua was over matched in buffalo in week
17.
he was you know fish out of water really
you know i didn't mean to make that pun
there with the dolphins but they're not
really a fish they're
that's all right they're not fish so it
doesn't matter right so camel out of
water but
but either way right mammal out of water
there and that was
you know so we'll see where it goes
i'm certainly not sold i i really wonder
how sold the dolphins are
and that's that's what we're going to
have to look for here as the off season
unfolds
and no reason to tell us now that they
may not be sold
it would screw things up if they don't
find someone better and they preserve
their position of strength as they
consider
a veteran free agent as they consider
what they may do in the draft whatever
the case may be but the warning signs
are there just the fact that they had to
use a relief pitcher
in a league full of guys who pitch
complete
games yeah that's enough for tua and
anyone else to say
something's not right here hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports